[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur diagonale tv
spéciale leçon pour débutants on va voir
aujourd'hui la règle du rock alors
qu'est ce que le rock comment peut-on
rock et quel est l'intérêt du rock
comment peut-on empêcher rock on va voir
ça aujourd'hui avec nino maso rasé
bonjour ni nos jours alors pourquoi
hockey déjà ses caisses que ce que c'est
quoi leur offre quel est l'intérêt de
soukous donc le rock ça sert assez que
vous avez votre roi mettre en lieu sûr
et en même temps qu'en maine et de
l'anjou la tour parce que le rock c'est
le goût unique où on a joué deux pièces
en même temps le roi et le tour donc ça
permet de gagner temps mais qu'on nous
ait du temps parce que on joue encore
quand c'est notre retrait en parant et
là on va faire beaucoup
en même temps quand même temps alors je
crois que c'est le seul coup qui permet
de jouer deux pièces en même temps c'est
le seul oui voilà ça arrive jamais sauf
fawcett cas donc savoir wii à savoir
donc l'idée c'est en général de placer
le roi derrière les pièces on va voir
ici mais difficilement menacer ici on a
les blancs
ici qui peuvent faire le rock alors
l'europe se jouer des deux côtés alors
c'est en fait le roi qui se déplacent de
deux cases donc existe un leurs cours et
le rock longue comme on dit dans
certains pays et où petit rock grand
roque le sont employées en france
donc petit rock ce sera le côté où ça se
fait plus courtemanche à droite et camp
rock voilà à gauche mais le roi se
déplace toujours de deux cases en fait
on y grand roque
mais le roi plus loin mais ça c'est donc
vraiment une 4è exceptionnel on a déjà
appris que le roi se déplace uniquement
sur ansell qu'à chaque fois bien sûr et
l'a donc ne vous trompez pas n'émettait
pas le roi juste à côté
mais vous avez 300 nouveaux lits et
places et le roi directement sur doc à
ses fans
alors ils sont de petits rock voilà si
on vire up héros alors une assez magique
quand l'amour l'atome il va aussi donc
là d'apparaître voilà la tour va faire
un petit saut et se placer à gauche
jouera c'est pour ça qu'on dit que ça
mais à la fois le roi à l'abri puisque
on voit qu'il est derrière ses pions
bien abrité de l'adversaire et en même
temps la tour qui vient en joue oui donc
ça on peut dire oh comme n'ai pas su
mieux que ray que c'est pratiquement une
logique presque aux échecs mais l'idée
c'est donc de permettre aux joueurs
puisque environ perroquet comme avec les
blancs
comme avec le noir également l'idée
s'est un peu accéléré les jeux d'échecs
qui déjà longue donc tout de suite donc
emmener la tour tout de suite et
savamment thibault accéléré donc ça
accélère un peu le cheval
on l'a vu le petit côté ici mais alors
on peut aussi donc faire le rock
exactement la même façon de l'autre côté
donc le roi bouge toujours de deux cases
on appelle ça le grand côté le grand
roque parce que le roi pas du grand côté
il ya plus de calcul à 3,4 il ya trois
cases entre le roi et la tour alors
qu'il ya ici en a que deux mais le roi
va pas de trois cases le droit va
toujours de deux cases donc on va
montrer le coup tout simplement ici et
là tu auras pareil j'étais à côté
et voilà donc la même façon la tour 1 va
se retrouver juste à droite du roi
inversement le côté la tour va à gauche
devront donc regarder la tour rip se met
en jeu directement
elle est placée ici au centre et donc
elle a une action dans le jeu centrale
alors que le roi s'est abrité derrière
une petite barrière de pions et on le
met bien à l'abri donc on vous rappelle
qu'elle heureux que vous pourrez faire
une seule fois pendant toute la partie
on peut pas faire que deux fois c'est à
dire aucune fois après déplacer les
pieds selref par exem fois petit rock
l'autre fois camp rock non ça se fait
une seule fois pendant toute la partie
et après il ya pas mal d'interdiction
aussi l'espère c'est vrai que les cas
quand on ne peut pas faire ou alors on
va voir quand même montré jeudi gien
pour s'amuser juste alors on peut faire
un grand roque ici et les noirs pour
répliquer de la même façon par an grand
roc de leur côté par exemple ou au maire
un petit rock ici de ce côté là où la
toho s'il revient organes donc ça vous
avez l'habitude durant
maintenant effectivement il ya des cas
on peut pas faire le record c'est quoi
c'est quand première cas le plus
élémentaire à retenir il faut pas
qu'elles les pieds soit déjà déplacé il
faut pas que vos rois où vous avez déjà
touché ni tournis le roi donc donc il a
déjà bougé pendant la partie par exemple
il est allé sur benetton peut montrer
sur eux d'où par exemple
par exemple si vous jouez ici le roi
vient à eux deux les noirs est rond le
grand roque vous révéler orient par
exemple ils font par exemple quelque
chose il l'a osé tout petit je suis bien
placé je vais faire le rock mais non ça
marcherait plus elle vous pouvez pas
vous
le geste ils refusent parce que les gars
ça n'existe pas on n'a plus le droit
donc il faut pas avoir bougé ni le roi
ni le lait n'ont donc ce sera la même
chose si on pouvait les noirs lits de
camp rock tour et après on réunit accès
tour donc ça marche pareil si les noirs
donc ici on a joué le roi aux assurés
par exemple ici on joue le roi a eu deux
on pourra plus rock et pas les noirs qui
font tourner vite au bébé on reviendrait
sur la case 1 les noirs reviendrait sur
la casa 8 et bien il est blanc de ce
côté là ni de celui là puisque le roi à
bouger ne peuvent bloquer les noirs ne
peuvent par ok du grand côté mais par
contre il peut compter ils peuvent du
petit côté donc il va vous faire péter
horrocks un niveau pas parce que j'ai
ouï parce que j'ai joué tac ici où je
joue à notre cou par exemple
effectivement je joue en l2 hélas les
noirs peuvent jouer le petit prince est
par contre ils ne posent pas jouer le
grand voilà on peut jouer les chercheurs
ont donc déjà cette règle très important
à retenir
voilà de ne pas oublier pas avoir bougé
ni le roi ni là qu'est ce qui se passe
et si vous avez oublié que vous pouviez
déjà votre roue et vous vous avez envie
quand même de faire recommander le
tournoi vous ils ont ou dire c'est
interdit si votre adversaire souviennent
que vous avez déjà obligé le roi il va
appeler l' arbitre ils vont vous dire
que vous avez touché cette pièce
maintenant il faut que vous jouez avec
le roi
comme vous avez déjà vous expliquer une
fois pillée se toucher il faut il faut
faire voilà donc si comme le roi surgit
un lourd de rock on peut vous demander
que le roi reste survient parce que cet
arrêt sera un coup illégal
tu vas 7 à 26 ans de l'euro comme le roi
baissé de riches par exemple sur gyan ça
fait deux cas c'est déjà ça c'est pas un
coup naturel
oui donc cette fois votre adversaire n'a
pas droit réclamer nos juste laisser le
roi est pas la tour donc maintenant une
chose quand même a fait attention si
vous jouez un tournoi tenais pas touché
quand même il fait c'est important lourd
de coûts n'est pas touchée la taureau
première pourquoi parce que si vous
commencez quand on fait de retards
burruchaga tour après le roi si on joue
l'on touche là ton il faut jouer voilà
il faut jouer la tour ça va pas dire
forcément quand vous adversaires ils ont
droit de dire non
vous avez joué lès tours par exemple on
va montrer comment on essaye par exemple
air rock avec en jouant la tour grand
roque avec voilà on met la tour ici par
exemple avec tours dia parce qu'on à
nous de faire droit à faire apparaître
sur six roues est là comme ça mais on
n'a plus droit une fois vous avez lâché
pillet sont a dit voilà on irait sur la
place donc ici vous avez lâché la tour
c'est à dire que le rock est un coup
droit en fait ouais il faut commencer et
l'autre après si vous jouez avec votre
ami ou extérieur entre les amis c'est
pas grave j'imagine immo vous tolérez
mais sa hausse tolère pas d'accord je
pense que toulouse est fini nous je vais
résumer c'est à dire que le rock est un
coup droit
et si je joue la tour en premier j'ai
pas le droit de rock et que de bouger la
tour sinon donc si je joue la tour je me
suis je voulais faire le grand roque si
je joue la tour là en dix ans après je
bois ce leurs notes ce côté là non on
n'a pas le droit
si on veut faire leur offre faut jouer
le roi en premier ses passagers par les
canaux jouer avec le roux en première
mais on protéger un coup illégal pas
normal parce que le roi se turent
d'oggaz la personne ne peut vous
demander
laissez le roi sur cette case mais par
contre la tour il est déjà joué donc
fait mais là on pourrait quand même
faire le petit rôle puisqu'on n'a pas
oui là où malgré qu'on sait pas parce
qu'on perd le droit du grand roque ont
perdu mon père voire du petit rock du
moment comme un jouet ni le roi ni la
tour c'est possible alors maintenant on
va voir des cas où le rock est
impossible donc alors ici déjà
déjà il faut savoir nous on vous a
montré les exemples c'est déjà les cases
libres entre la tour et le roi donc si
il est les pièces placées entre le roi
et le tour vous pourrez jamais rockets
là par exemple cavaliers empêche empêche
rock voilà même s'il y avait eu un fou
ici on n'a pas le droit de timbre sens
il faudrait mettre la tour sur le foot
donc on a pas ou qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire il faut sortir d'abord ses
cavaliers alors on sort le cavalier par
exemple ici plus ou moins n'importe où
vous voulez voilà esayan vers le centre
et ses eaux noires de jouer alors si les
noirs jouent le coup h5
par exemple ici oui là on oublierait
faire recours on peut en plus rauque et
si vous avez un billet sur cc n'est
jamais obligatoire faut pas avoir bougé
le roi ni la tour ici c'est le cas on
est dans une partie qui va jouer ni le
roi ni métaux donc ici par contre il est
donc les autres règles maintenant quand
on peut pas faire le rock
si il y à un échec si le roi est souple
et j'ai alors on va voir dans ces cas
vous avez pas droit de faire rock
imaginons
cavalière 3 alors les noirs jouent au
lieu de jouer le coup h5 joue le coup
fourré 4 par exemple et chez qu on voit
bien qu'il ya un échec ici voilà le roi
est un échec sous la prise du fou et on
se dit bah super très bien c'est pas
grave je vais faire l'europe a retiré
voilà puisqu'à la fin je ne serai pas en
échec mais on n'a pas le droit mais
bizarrement non les règles ne donne pas
le droit de faire ça et s'échapper comme
ça c'est facilement voilà si vous avez
chic d'abord il faut jouer soit
interposés une pièce entre aux bougies
avec le roi mais si on bouge et le roi
rappellez vous vous avez plus de rendre
au caire après une fois le roi bouger
dans la partie exact
dans ces cas soient où vous allez mener
la pièce moi interposés quelque chose
entre c'est le plus souvent on
interposés quelque chose par exemple
dans cette position qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire donc ce alors pas faire rejouer
cavaliers ici alors là on serait embêté
si on veut faire robe parce que si les
noirs prennent le cavalier échec
ben voilà on ne soit en bouche le roi
comprend le fou mais on pourra y rouler
doré rock comme on dit souvent on pourra
plus rock et donc par exemple on veut
interpose les pions voilà on interpose
l'opion donc là le pou ne fait plus cher
puisqu'il est buté par le pion et si les
noirs prennent le pion on reprend et là
on prépare le rock
sauf que c'est au noir de jouer et joue
un autre coup alors ils font pas échec
ils font fou à 6 y'a pas échec tant qu
alors je ne peux me dire mais je vais
faire le rock ça y est donc vous avez
bien retenir que sur échec ou n'a pas
droit de faire rock mais en même temps
ici disposition non plus je pas le droit
alors pourquoi parce que si elle est
lurons ans priscilla si il ya une case
que l'heureux doit passer où il sert a
donc menacés comme c'est le cas de gaz
est fait ici il n'a pas droit non plus
de repas large et pas en manquer parce
que je passe ou une case où je suis sous
le feu de l'ennemi en fait je risque oui
en une balle voilà c'est ça un petit peu
oui flèche donc chez laser je rêvais les
13 laser donc on peut pas on peut pas
falloir non plus parce que l'adversaire
contrôle tout simplement alors ça peut
être fait par un cavalier imaginons
qu'un cavalier soit ici sur cette quasi
contrôlerait aussi cette case donc quand
l'adversaire effectivement contrôler la
case de passage du roi et bien on n'a
pas le droit non plus de rock et donc
non seulement n'a pas d'ordre aux kings
un échec on joue le coup c2 c3 alors les
noirs peuvent prendre ici en faisant
échec pour empêcher l'europe mais
peuvent aussi jouer directement même le
coup issifou à 6
ici se fout on contrôle la case et donc
le roi ne peut pas roquet et donc la
tour ne peut pas rentrer en jeu elle est
toujours dans le coin et le roi reste au
centre
voilà donc ça c'est les deux
possibilités dans mon cas par ok quand
on a bougé le roi on peut par ok quand
on a bougé la tour sous laquelle on fait
avec laquelle on veut faire le rock
si on bouge l'autre tour c'est plus non
on peut parier que le moment où on est
en échec et on peut par ok si
l'adversaire contrôler une case où on
passe son échec alors par contre est-ce
qu'on a droit de roque et si on a été en
échec
on a été il ya par exemple imaginons
alors cette position donc ici échec au
roi imaginons que je fasse le coup c 3
les noirs jouent le coup food et 6 et
puis je crois que l'adversaire est midi
mais t'as pas le droit puisque je t'ai
fait bien sûr on a trois cantons a été
mis en échec si on n'abat pas bougé le
roi pour parer les chèques
on a toujours le droit de route alors on
vous montre peut-être une dernière
exemple en thibault marand par exemple
prévenu sur quelques coups derrière avec
x 6 peut-être à un moment qu'on faisait
donc là par exemple imaginons ont fait
p3 n'importe quoi on attend parce qu'on
veut faire au québec et en asie y
compris les jeunes auxquels une noire je
sais pas pourquoi ils font fouet fin
vous placez fin alors autonome qu'est ce
qui se passe était fait
ça serait pas mal donc alors là si on
prend le fou on a en plus de rendre au
quai six migrants on n'aura plus droit
de roquette jusqu'au bout droit
d'évoquer ici j'ai pas le droit non plus
et pourquoi pas ce qu'est cette règle de
cannes et les pieds ce milieu s'applique
pas uniquement qu'est il ya nos pièces
au milieu de tours et le roi mais aussi
ça peut être le pied cet adversaire est
là aussi vous n'avez pas droit des
entreprises et en même temps faire rock
ça s'est un peu rare mais ça peut
arriver facilement là le joug c'est une
charge le fou par exemple et là aussi on
peut par ok non voilà donc ça c'est un
coup aussi qui empêchent leurs hommes
dont l'âge est immense une autre règle
encore complémentaires d'anciennes il ya
des pièces entre le roi et la tour que
ce soit de son propre camp du camp
adverse on ne peut pas ok non plus nous
voilà la règle est relativement simple
ne pas bouger ni le roi ni la tour avec
laquelle on on veut faire l'europe pas
de pièces au milieu ne pas être un échec
au monde en europe vous avez pu être en
échec-avant mais du monde n'avait pas
bougé ni le roi ni la tour pour paris
ces échecs il n'y a pas de problème tout
ce qui est en échec le monde dur vous
avez pas le droit il faut parer les
chèques et ensuite si l'adversaire
contrôle
les cases où passe le roi et bien ce
n'est pas possible non plus et n'oubliez
pas donc vous faites le rock une seule
fois pendant toute la partie d'une seule
fois depuis longtemps que la partie à
droite ou à gauche grand roque petit
rock
voilà merci nino pour cette leçon sur
l'europe coup fondamentale aux échecs
le rock est important il faut en général
le faire assez vite donc pas trop
traîner ça fera l'objet serait de leçons
il va être long mais terminer ses cours
avec vous vous êtes laissé un petit pot
stratégiquement aussi encore une fois
pourquoi donc on fait eurocop aussi que
vous ne connaissez pas encore mais dans
les courses suivantes on va un moment
passé aussi pour vous sur les parties
exemplaire mais vous allez après
remarquer et le plus souvent on
recommence commenté la partie commençait
la partie avec les coûts de pion central
pour ouvrir nos pieds ce qu'on vous a
parlé dans je ne sais plus quoi
troisième court donc après une fois les
pieds un pouce et les roues et indigo
affaibli parce que les échecs on vous
expliquait dans des cours devient plus
probable est plus facile pour
l'adversaire faire le ménage sur votre
roi alors le rock le plus souvent ses
conseillers si vous pions sont toujours
placés sur deuxième branche ou troisième
à la limite et vous cacher derrière les
pions les bras mais les tours comme on
disait dans le centre mais vous ne
conseille pas faire recolle dans une
position où il ya eu qu'une puis on
restait dans cette côte est et le roi ne
se cache pas disons mais plutôt ça
expose le roi donc l'euro l'europe ce
sera vraiment placer le roi derrière vos
pièces tongres et nsr guerrero piste
derrière surtout les pions où il va
sécuriser
voilà exactement donc voilà donc jeu
qu'on a fait le tour de ce coup très
intéressant à connaître évidemment le
rock ou le seul coup aux échecs qui se
joue une fois dans la partie et qui
permet de bouger deux pièces en même
temps le roi et la tour voilà nous vous
remercions d'avoir suivi cette leçon
spécial débutant sur le rock sur des
bonal tv merci nino n'est rien et bon
courage à nos spectateurs au revoir
[Musique]